the star of no time to die actor rami
malek
okay
and finally from snl pete davidson
that's rami malek and pete davidson
hilariously playing each other on
saturday night live do i have to sit
next to romney malik
i mean his eyes are freaking me out but
dude stop staring at me man
i'm sorry like just that people say we
look alike the actor made his hosting
debut on the legendary comedy show and
besides his resting villain face people
tell me i have what's called a resting
villain face
like this is my totally neutral
he took on the role of davidson in a
sketch called celeb school
romney malek did you see where wheezy
went
no i've been staring at pete davidson oh
please make him stop it's like the soul
of a victorian child is trapped in his
eyes
but things took a turn when the dynamic
duo did a parody of the netflix hit show
squid
[Music]
game at least i think it is
it's no secret that davidson has played
the oscar winner a few times over the
years he debuted his malik impression
during the season 42 premiere back in
2016 during a sketch for the actor's
emmy-winning role in mr robot
it seems you backed up your photos to
your online website don't know how you
did it it's actually
really hard to do well i got a photo
shoot with amtrak magazine that i'm two
days late for so
thanks for this man
malik who currently stars in the latest
james bond movie no time to die
spoke to e.t ahead of his snl hosting
debut how are you preparing for that
stent um how are you feeling about it
uh
i'm thrilled i'm thrilled i can't say of
course there's some nerves coursing
through through my bloodstream but it's
great it'll be you know a couple
couple weeks after the film comes out so
who knows what we're going to do i don't
i i'm sure there'll be some some
sketches with with a villain or two in
them
and by villain he probably meant his
double 07 co-star daniel craig who made
a surprise cameo during a
prince-inspired sketch so he kicks it
and he misses
[Applause]
hey
get off me double nope ugly
how was that
that was bad
but you're james bonds you got the part